الاطار هيك التفكير طبعا مش العقل
المؤامرات او يعني حالتي حاله العجز على
الاخر الذي يخرب علينا هناءه العيش
ولكن ربما يكون صحيح القول انه الغرب بشكل
عام ليس لصالحه ان ان يكون المغرب العربي
والمشرق العربي
جنوب الكوكب اذا صح لقول والعرب تحديدا
لانه في مركز السنوات الطاقه الاشياء يعني
ان يشهد نوع من من بناء الدوله الوطنيه
الديمقرا في همم الدوله الحديثه ومعنى
المواطن ومعنى للفرد وتتحول هذه الدول الى
الدول الدول
الغربيه صحيح انا اتفق معك اراء ان اليوم
طبعا وهذا همم
قديم معروف ان همم الغرب لا يريد ابدا
لبلد اخر
خاصه البلاد العربيه ان تكون
متطوره وديموقراطيه دعكه من كلام بوش
وغيلو لما غزل عراقي كلام الغرب دموي
تاريخ الغرب دموي
وقلت هذا الكلام اكثر من مره الغرب خبيث
لا اناني الغرب ونرجسيه الغرب ترى الاخر
خاصه الدول العربيه
كاسان كائنات من نوع
اخرتنا نحن في بلاد العربيه
اننا نواجهنا هذا الخطاب وقد وعى به
النهضه
كثير من السياسي
صحيحا
طويلا في ممحات والمسجلات والردود الشعار
والسياسيه فتدخلت
هذا الخطاب تدخل على حساب ما هو علمي
تكنولوجيا
في دائما لما نتحدث عن المستقبل العربيه
يجب ان نحتاج هناك اليوم تحدي التكنولوجيا
ووسائل التواصل الاجتماعي والرقميات
العالم سيكون
مرافق العالم ستكون هل البلاد العربيه
الان تبني فكره رقميا تبني فكرا تكنولوجيا
عميقا
ايه مراكز الدراسات تهتم بهذا الموضوع
تقنيه انا لا اقصد ولكن انا ما اقصد هو ال
ال المنظومه هل نحن نؤسس لمنظومه فكريه
شامله
لتجديد المعطى العقلي وفقا
لتحديات الثوره الصناعيه الرابعه وبناء
رؤيا رؤيا للمستقبل